hadja fanta nouvelle série weeds n'ont
pas tous voyez je suis bientôt
indépendant qui aiment pas beaucoup
d'argent c'est parce que vous croyez
ça m'avait soufflé j'ai beau et riche ça
n'améliore pas du tout mon cardio
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo il
ya un an je vous avais donné des
conseils qui valait de l'or pour devenir
connus sur youtube aujourd'hui
maintenant que vous êtes connu je vais
vous donner des conseils
avoir un maximum d'argent pour
rentabiliser votre gloire et votre
célébrité pour monétiser vos femmes dans
la plus grande des discrétions car il ne
voulait pas que la règle numéro une
nouvelle influenceurs sait qu'il n'a pas
le droit de bien gagner sa vie est de
gagner de l'argent c'est formellement
interdit
mais je n'en fais pas je me suis adapté
j'ai trouvé des petites techniques
agréable affaires qui vous rendront
riche mais personne n'en sont par contre
vous allez voir jouer sur les mots et
manipulable communauté mais c'est pas
grave on veut de l'argent on est là pour
sa bande l aller
les amis la première technique elle est
tellement connue que valence est devenue
la norme seller vidéo de 10 minutes 0
pourquoi des vidéos d'emi 0 1 mais
question parce qu'on peut mettre autant
de pub qu'on voit dans la vidéo un
support sable est jeune ça fait du bruit
mec c'est un enfer c'est un enfer en
effet tous les youtuber qui garde ses
vidéos le savent mais nos communautés le
savent moins quand tu fais une vidéo de
plus de 10 minutes tu as la possibilité
d'ajouter autant de pub que tu veux à
l'intérieur de celle-ci plus une à la
fin mais bon c'est là il dérange pas les
gens puisqu'ils sont arrivés au bout de
la vidéo du guide la vidéo est il la
regarde pas mais celle au milieu je ne
peux rien faire contre tu regarde une
vidéo tu vois le petit trait jaune se
rapprocher petit à petit du rhône tu vas
l'avoir cette pub mais tu achèteras le
produit qu'elle met en avant tu es sur
youtube pour ça
[Musique]
notre contenu étant gratuit les amis il
faut bien qu'on gagne notre vie dure
mais pas quatre pubs on peut pas faire
nos courses attendait les 4000 euros par
mois ça ne suffit pas pour faire ses
courses non non on veut les 15 km
aisance et les gens vous adorent ils
veulent vous soutenir une slave comme
bonne situation financière est compliqué
alors ils regarderont ces pubs avec
plaisir et vous allez vous enrichirez
pouvoir faire vos courses dans les
magasins les plus prestigieux de la
planète tout en continuant d'y auprès de
votre communauté en toute impunité
voilà c'est une petite technique bon
toute façon tout le monde le fait déjà
moi même je fais des combats en vrai
séparément et technique mais là on
rentre dans les vrais dossiers c'est
maintenant
deuxième technique le code créateur fort
night la meilleure de toutes les
techniques c'est tellement fou les gens
ne savent pas combien de gens utilisent
votre code et ne savent pas combien ça
vous a rapporté d'argent ils n'en ont
aucune idée plus les sommes que vous
touchez sont flous aux yeux des gens
mieux c'est répandez votre code créateur
fornas est comme la pesse je veux que
les gens ne pensent qu'à ça envoyez leur
des images subliminales pendant vos live
quand vous prenez les transports voulu
marquer sur votre front sur le frigo
chez vous mettez un post it avec votre
code créateur tout le monde joue à fond
avec vos parents votre frère votre soeur
et même peut-être votre grand mère ça
fait cinq personnes qui utilisent votre
code créateur c'est déjà ça de gagné
chaque centime compte des amis chaque
centime et les gens n'ont aucune idée de
la somme que ça a généré alors vous
pourrez à côté de ça continue à faire
des opv bien juteuse en vous faisant
passer pour quelqu'un qui gagne pas bien
sa vie pour que les gens soient ok avec
le contenu mais redit que vous proposez
fait la règle numéro 3 elle est très
important quand vous faites quelque
chose pour gagner de l'argent n'est pas
pour gagner de l'argent c'est pour payer
vos employés c'est pour pouvoir aller
faire vos courses c'est pour pouvoir
payer votre loyer c'est pour financer
vos futurs projets qui ne sortiront
jamais étant donné que vos projets qui
coûte cher à réaliser comme des vidéos
avec de la grosse production ce sera
probablement une marque qui sponsorisera
la vidéo en question et du coup vous
donnera les fonds nécessaires à sa
réalisation mais en aucun cas vous ne
dites aux gens que c'est pour vous
acheter une très belle voiture que c'est
pour vous acheter en à part de 200
mètres carrés ou pour vous acheter une
montre de luxe ou partir en vacances en
couple dans de superbes hôtels non non
et non les gens doivent croire que vous
gagnez la même chose qu'eux elles
doivent surtout pas comprendre que vous
gagnez très bien votre vie sinon ils
seront beaucoup moins indulgent avec
vous lorsque vous ferez des op les gens
auront compris la douille alors faites
attention à ça
quatrième conseil fait toujours en sorte
d'être vu comme un indépendant
indépendant rime avec personne qui
triment et quichard bonne pour un
salaire pas si dingue ce qui est faux il
ya plein d'indépendants qui gagnent très
bien leur vie mais qui reste indépendant
pour autant et c'est très cool mais les
gens n'ont pas cette image l'un d'eux
alors même si vous avez un gros chiffre
d'affaires que vous avez des employés
vous avez une vraie structure derrière
des gens qui vous aident fait comme si
tout ça ça n'existait pas pourquoi parce
que la personne qui regarde vos vidéos
se sentira importante cruciale
elle aura la sensation d'aider quelqu'un
qui fonce droit dans le mur si on lui
apporte pas notre aide est laide
principal de cette personne c'est son
indulgence
elle va nous permettre de faire des op
dégueulasse sans rien dire sans broncher
car elle pense qu'on en a vraiment
besoin pour survivre alors que pas du
tout
mais on les veut le chien en or ou les
boeufs cinquième conseil si c'est
vraiment la crise pauvres que vous
enchaînez les op ou vous êtes payés pour
jouer un jeu et que les gens peu de
papier se mettent à un peu gueulé parce
qu'ils n'acceptent pas vous gagnez de
l'argent puisque vous n'avez jamais rien
fait pour qu'ils acceptent que vous
gagnez de l'argent vous lancez le sort
divorce douglas c'est un sport très
puissant notre public n'a aucune
connaissance de la comptabilité et des
chiffres que nous générons alors nous
pouvons très facilement jouer sur les
mots quelqu'un dit à égal trop bien sa
vie c'est sûr dit lu votre salaire dans
mon cas
400 euros par mois jeudi comme pas bon
mais là vous croyez pas parce que c'est
impossible que gm 400 euros par mois
mais si j'avais dit une somme un peu
plus cohérente genre 2000 3000 les gens
auraient cru et basta mais que des 10
pour encaisser de l'argent en france il
faut soit être salarié de l'entreprise
soit avoir sa propre entreprise
et quand on a sa propre entreprise on se
met salariés de notre propre entreprise
notre propre entreprise elle encaisse
tout à 100 les revenus liés aux cette
pub qui a dans nos vidéos dix minutes de
runes et elle encaisse aussi les opc les
deux sources d'argent d'un youtube
heures ou marque si vous avez une mare
ou mersch si vous vendez du maire
alors ça c'est chiffre d'affaires bien
entendu il faut soustraire les charges
pour obtenir le bénéfice mais les
charges d'un youtube heures c'est du
matériel qu'ils achètent une fois tous
les trois ans et un ou deux monteurs qui
paie tous les mois et c'est un loyer
pour payer la wii tourner ses vidéos
donc chiffre d'affaires mois les charges
et en pourcentage ça représente 40% du
chiffre d'affaires donc
l'ue reste 60 % de la somme puisque
cession d'entreprise en fin d'année va
se verser les petites dividendes et ça
arrivera directement sur son compte et
encore parfois on n'avait pas besoin de
verser des sommes dingues sur notre
compte parce que l'on peut acheter des
trucs directement avec notre carte
d'entreprise les gens n'ont pas idée que
ce camp caisse votre entreprise c'est à
vous c'est votre argent aussi vous
pouvez simplement pas acheter ce que
vous voulez avec parce que c'est sur
l'entreprise donc ça doit servir à
l'entreprise par exemple vous pouvez
acheter une voiture pour dire elle
attend c'est pour aller au travail ça
compte vous pouvez vous payer un petit
voyage et dire ouais mais à tanger ton
d'un blog
ça compte vous pouvez vous acheter des
pc des micros du matériel à l'infini
vous pouvez dire ouais c'est pour me
laver mes vidéos donc toutes vos grosses
dépenses finalement vous les faites avec
votre entreprise directement donc en
fait vous êtes très riche mais les gens
vont se baser sur le salaire et le
salaire vous versez il est très bas
pourquoi pour sa limbourg groupe donc
verser vous les moins gros salaires
possible mais faut que ce soit quand
même crédible vous avait soustrait les
charges il vous reste trente mille euros
sur votre entreprise va vous verser 2000
2005 alors qu'ambri il reste 25 milles
qui sont à vous sur l'entreprise si
votre salaire est très bas vous pouvez
dire la douille des droits d'auteur
c'est très flou les gens n'ont aucune
idée de ce que vous rapporte vos droits
d'auteur mais nous nous le savons très
bien en faisant tout ça vous contribuez
à vous faire voir comme un créateur
indépendant qui a des revenus modestes
alors qu'en réalité vous avez des
revenus très conséquent alors retour de
flamme ça contribue au fait que la
communauté n'accepte pas que des gens
gagnent de l'argent et donc ceux qui
veulent est honnête vont se prendre le
feu mais ça c'est pas mon problème
dernières techniques et celle là
prenez-en de la graine
elle envoie du lourd en plus de toucher
un maximum de tune les gens vous prendre
comme modèle parce que vous allez faire
une bonne action mais cette bonne action
elle a pour but en réalité que vous
engranger un maximum d'argent dans votre
poche
mais ça les gens ne le savent pas vous
devez faire une vidéo qui tourne autour
de l'argent étonnant n'est ce pas ces
sites à bout après notre communauté
et pourtant dans cette situation là ça
passe parce que le but c'est de le
donner à des gens cet argent vous allez
donner plusieurs milliers d'euros c'est
beaucoup mais par rapport à ce que vous
engrangez toute l'année c'est pas c'est
conséquent encore une fois vous devez
jouer sur ce que les gens ne savent pas
sur ce dans quoi les gens ne peuvent pas
se douter alors pour justifier ces
sommes que vous allez donner d'une
manière ou d'une autre aux gens vous
allez faire un placement de produits à
un placement produit honnête vous dites
à votre communauté vous jouez sur
l'honnêteté les gens ne trouveront net
en plus ce sera encore mais pour votre
image
on va prendre le discours de la marque
on va le dire tel quel on va faire trois
minutes horrible mais après il y aura le
concept on donne de l'argent et ça c'est
bon l'image est sauvé et vous allez
faire comprendre de manière manuelle aux
gens que ce placement était nécessaire
pour pouvoir faire les dons conséquents
par la suite mais qu'en est il en
réalité que n'est ni déjà vous auriez pu
vous passez du placement pour faire les
dons parce que vous êtes déjà riche et
en plus j'avais gardé au moins 90 % de
la somme dans votre poche mais ça les
gens ne le savent pas vous allez donc
vous enrichir tout en redorant votre
image et en vous faisant passer pour
l'abbé pierre et là vous vous dites mais
xavier tb oui quand j'ai cette chaîne je
m'appelle vous avez pourquoi ton
placement dégueulasse là d'une minute tu
le fais pas au début n'importe quelle
vidéo est juste a su nous on n'en veut
pas si on avait une opportunité de
gagner de l'argent en présentant un truc
pendant une minute au début d'une vidéo
on le ferait alors fait n'ya pas de
souci mais vous êtes malade ou quoi
aller où mon image du créateur
indépendant qui gagnent pas beaucoup et
où je peux pas faire ça vous rendez vous
compte vous allez montrer aux gens
directement que vous donnez des milliers
d'euros à d'autres gens pour payer une
boîte de prod et produire un contenu
très cali est très cool mais on n'est
pas là pour ça ayé une boîte de prod la
blague
moi je paye un trépied et j'ai besoin de
rien d'autre
attendez je ne reçois un mail d'une
marque bonjour ce que j'adore votre
profil et nous aimerions collaborer avec
toi nous aimerions tu met en avant notre
appliqué sur un succès ou [ __ ] creator
déjà plus d'un milliard de
téléchargements dans le monde en france
dans une introduction d'environ deux
minutes au début d'une autre vidéo
devrait tuer des grives répit et que tu
met l'accent sur tous les accessoires et
les différents qu'elle propose votre
budget et de miron attendait mais vous
pensez à ce que je pense mais galles et
laurence aloir moi ça va très bien
désolé je suis essoufflée
j'ai dû courir les marches du métro y
avait du monde c'était bouchées doubles
et comme j'ai rendez vous dans une heure
et demie avec une astuce fait que je me
dépêche pour a le temps de faire cette
vidéo dès aujourd'hui on va faire quoi
on va aider des petits créateurs
indépendants quand on besoin sur twitch
les gens qui font entre 0 et 50 viewer
qui sont nouveaux dans le truc ou en
tout cas qui sont pas des gens qui méga
marche on va les aider dans cette
période c'est un peu galère où tu viens
de quitter ton taf et te mettre à plein
temps à sa passion mais où ça génère pas
trop d'argent donc tu sers en place un
tueur à la fin du mois on va les aider
voilà moi j'aurais adoré à l'époque on
fait ça donc c'est parti par contre
qu'on va faire des dons assez conséquent
il ya une appli mobile qui sponsorise
cette vidéo et du coup avec l'argent qui
me donne je mettrai une partie dans les
dons du coup c'est le moment un peu de
vent du mais c'est pour la bonne cause
windows vous comprenez l'appeler mon
bilan question ça s'appelle molecule
c'est une api au fait vous pouvez faire
votre propre personnage qui vous
ressemble c'est marrant voilà se servir
pour faire une photo de profil ou un
petit gag sur twitter ça passe bien il a
quand même un grand coeur sur youtube
heures alors c'est un mec ces gens un
truc super cool
il ya plein de n'est dispo rire il ya le
petit écrasé pas mal cette appli le nez
il n'existe rien ne compte pas un très
gros mais le giga pif lie à la trompette
lui c'est la clarinette
je crois qu'on commence à avoir saisi le
concept maintenant à personne maman
merci à vraiment c'est cool alors
maintenant on va passer aux dons à l'est
la partie coup là-bas enfin bordel de
merde
pardon maman donc là j'ai faire des dons
énorme alors dans les petits créateurs
la just chatting on va checker les
petites chaînes
ok regardez je suis tombé sur un gars on
parle on regarde il a l'air très gentil
on allait faire un don on va l'aider on
va l'aider on va l'aider 1500 beats et
21 euros convient de lui donner un beat
sa réaction du match mais à lego a
laissé rexall great falls ericsson va
être vol vous même monsieur merci pour
le bit la vie tu attends moi tu as fait
ton monte un peu à vide ces mecs là on a
craqué le slip au québec on passe à 100
beats assez chaud mais ça fait 1 euros
40 n'est qu'à live aid cantons là je
vais vous dire la fois que marine non
plus j'ai bien gentil mais quand même
alors ça y est c'est parti thanks a lot
guen
merci beaucoup encore une fois bon ok il
est vraiment mignon je vais lui donner
1000 là on craque à remerciements cullin
sinon ça n'a pas été possible merci on
recule encore une fois merci beaucoup et
c'est parti
jean tigana mousse merci beaucoup
t'inquiète 0 c'est ben moi dis moi tu
testes toutes les émeutes
est ce que c'est une manière maligne
pour que je passe à 2010 ce qui me
semble qu'il ya des émaux jusqu'à un
million à un truc du genre c'est mal
parti
mais est-il et il est à doha
il a doit aller moi je suis abbé pierre
[ __ ] mec ohlala bon bah écoutez c'est
la fin de cette vidéo merci ou en tulle
encore une fois c'est que grâce à eux
que j'ai pu faire ça c'est grace mercy
[ __ ] voilà ça vous dérange pas ce
genre dopé vous finalement on fait des
heureux mais n'était pas à me le dire en
tout cas moi vous lâche pas toucher de
ouf
mais voilà je vous dis à bientôt c'était
de bon coeur charles dumont merci
beaucoup
bonne vidéo ça [ __ ] je la mets c'est
la fin de cette petite vidéo que je me
suis régalé à faire toutes ses astuces
sont utilisés par beaucoup de youtube
heures et son vrai après toutes ces
années
j'en ai trop marre de voir des gars
juste vouloir se mettre bien mais ne pas
assumer de vouloir se mettre bien alors
qu'à aucune honte ya aucun mal à tout ça
si vous voulez vous mettre bien saoulé
faire des op alesi mais connaît vos
responsabilités et arrêter de toujours
vous dédouaner et moi je sais que ma
communauté sont pas les couilles que je
fasse des op je le vois bien avec ma
chaîne gaming et tous les gens s'en
foutent complètement soyez transparent
sûr ça si vous voulez lettre ne soyez
pas si vous voulez pas l'être mais ne
fait pas cet entre-deux de merde où vous
faites genre d'être transparent mais
vous fait comprendre que vous gagnez
modestement votre vie on travaille tous
sur youtube plus ou moins dures il ya
des gars qui bossent 70 heures par
semaine il n'y a aucune honte et gagner
de l'argent voilà c'était mon petit
message j'ai un peu craqué mon slip
c'est mon immaturité c'est comme ça j'ai
des trucs qui me révolte et je trouve ça
injuste qu'on bullshit des gens merci
d'avoir regardé et n'hésitez pas à
suivre les conseils vraiment si vous
êtes sur youtube vous avez zéro courage
et 0 envie de faire changer les
mentalités fait ça ça marche à tous les
coups
au revoir
vous
[Musique]